Trascrizione: Ana Birsa
Revisore: Sofia Ramundo
Molto bene!
(Risata)
Ri-nascita.
Che tema importante, no?
Che tema affascinante!
Ho sempre amato moltissimo questa parola,
anche se il prefisso "ri"
presuppone che qualcosa alla prima
non è andata del tutto bene.
Ciononostante, ri-nascita ha proprio in sé
qualcosa di tranquillizzante,
perché esprime la possibilità
di una seconda chance,
di una terza, di una quarta.
E nel suo vasto valore significativo
ospita un sacco di immagini metaforiche.
Dalle più comuni,
di quelle di tutti i giorni:
"Ho lavorato come una matta,
ho mal di schiena, distrutta!
Ho fatto una sauna, mi sono sentita...
ri-nascere!"
A quelli più esistenziali, no?
"Quel rapporto era un inferno.
Abbiamo sofferto tantissimo,
ho provato tanto dolore.
Poi ci siamo lasciati e dopo,
col tempo, mi sono sentita...
ri-nascere!"
Funziona!
Ri-nascita è un bel concetto, funziona!
È un bel modo di dire.
Ciononostante, non posso
che esprimere la mia...
avversità ai modi di dire.
Sì, perché il "modo di dire" è il modo
con cui "il dire" si nasconde
dietro una barricata di vaghezza
che esprime in un modo sbrigativo,
spesso inesatto, distratto,
la qualità di un sentimento,
la qualità di un'emozione,
la qualità di un'esperienza.
Sottraendole dignità.
E rendendola in qualche modo opaca.
Ma parliamo di ri-nascita!
Anzi, voglio farvi un esempio.
Quando ci si definisce offesi,
è un modo un po' borghese e
anaffettivo per non definirsi feriti.
Io preferisco di gran lunga
definirmi ferita profondamente,
perché quella ferita si mostra a me
in tutta la sua gravità,
in tutta la sua importanza,
in tutto il suo valore.
Sì, preferisco dire ferita che offesa.
Ma torniamo alla ri-nascita.
È una parola che ho usato tantissimo,
soprattutto quando ero adolescente.
Sì, perché quando si è ragazzi,
non siamo troppo armati per capire
e dare un valore alle esperienze.
E quindi si ricorre a un termine
così vago, per parlarne.
Ma ora,
che sono vecchia,
anche se faccio molto
per non sembrarlo, ma lo sono.
Beh, adesso ho un'urgenza.
Quella di dare un nome ai sentimenti.
Un nome esatto ai sentimenti,
un nome esatto alle emozioni,
un nome esatto alle esperienze.
E trovargli un luogo esatto nel mio animo.
L'esattezza mi convince, mi tranquillizza,
perché mi fa capire che quel sentimento,
quell'esperienza, quell'emozione,
io l'ho compresa,
l'ho accolta e l'ho fatta mia.
Quanto detesto la vaghezza.
Io amo l'esattezza, in tutto, eh!
In tutto, nelle cose più cretine anche.
Se ho bisogno di un materasso,
voglio che ci siano quei negozi
che si chiamano "Materasso mania".
Siamo sicuri che lì un materasso c'è.
Se ho bisogno di una vite o di un bullone,
certo non pretendo che esista
la "Fonte del bullone".
Ma l'esistenza di un ferramenta
mi tranquillizza.
Un'altra mia fissazione è la simmetria.
Mamma mia, una roba da vecchia proprio!
La simmetria: due vasi messi su un camino,
un punto A e un punto B
che delimitano uno spazio intermedio,
dove uno può mettere quello che vuole.
La foto di una vecchia parente,
una composizione di fiori,
una bella testa africana.
Ecco.
La signora Foer sta andando fuori tema.
No!
In realtà questo è il mio modo,
il materasso, la vita e la simmetria,
per esprimervi che alla mia età
si ha bisogno di certezze.
Si ha bisogno di capire con certezza
il proprio sentire, i propri sentimenti.
E anzi, si ha voglia, si ha necessità
che ogni sentimento abbia
il suo speculare, il suo opposto, no?
Rancore, perdono.
Levità, pesantezza.
Luminosità, oscurità.
Allora, in questo mio delirio,
senile un po', degli opposti
dato per valido il valore
della parola ri-nascita,
esiste la parola ri-morte?
No.
E io dove la metto la mia testa africana?
Qui barcollano le certezze.
Ma per fortuna tutti noi
abbiamo due certezze nella vita.
La nascita, il punto A,
e la morte, il punto B.
E nel mezzo c'è una cosa
meravigliosa, che è l'esistenza.
E anche una cosa ancora più meravigliosa,
è dare un senso alla propria esistenza.
No signori, non si ri-nasce,
perché non si ri-muore.
Finché si è in vita si è costretti
a essere in vita, a stare in vita.
A provare delle esperienze.
A provare sentimenti importanti,
come rabbia, dolore, amore, amicizia,
devozione, riconoscenza, appartenenza.
Ah! La vita ci da
la possibilità di scalzare
le nostre convinzioni
e sostituirle con altre
più fresche, più solide, più vigorose
che ci rappresentano di più.
In quel momento la vita
ci dà la possibilità di ri-crederci,
senza ri-morti o ri-nascite intermedie.
Tanto meno resurrezioni,
che è un privilegio che
è stato dato a pochi
e anche difficilmente
documentabile, trovo.
(Applausi)
Comunque...
Vi racconto,
vi racconto di me.
Quando ho perduto il mio
amato compagno, Hervé Foer,
era un uomo dolcissimo e molto solido.
Beh, quando lui è mancato,
io mi sono sentita completamente persa.
I miei pensieri erano
pieni di morte, non...
non volevo esistere più.
Ero così arrabbiata
che lui mi avesse lasciata da sola,
in questo mondo, ero terrorizzata.
I miei pensieri
erano di sparire, di morire.
Sarei voluto morire.
Ma niente.
La vita non mi ha concesso questo lusso.
Ho dovuto stare in vita.
In quella vita, nella mia vita
e fare i conti con la perdita...
del mio amato.
Ma è col tempo proprio
grazie al tempo della vita,
ho ri-trovato la mia stabilità.
Ho ri-scoperto il valore
delle piccole cose.
Ho trovato un posto all'amore
per il mio amato Hervé,
nel suo ri-cordo.
Non voglio certo convincere nessuno
a non usare più il termine ri-nascita.
Per il quale io voglio esprimere tutta...
tutto il mio rispetto.
Soprattutto nel suo valore letterario,
poetico, evocativo, mistico, religioso.
Nel suo valore animico.
Ma vi invito, tutte le volte
che vi è possibile,
di scegliere con cura il nome da dare
ai vostri movimenti interiori.
Ve ne sono di meravigliosi:
ri-trovarsi, ri-affacciarsi,
ri-tornare, ri-costruire.
E perché no, rivoluzionare.
Concludo,
esprimendo la mia totale antipatia
per la figura dell'araba fenice.
Questo uccellaccio agitato,
rumoroso, esibizionista
per autocombustione
che trovo anche volgare.
E nasce e ri-nasce,
e la cenere e il fuoco!
Mamma mia, un casinista,
troppo ingombrante!
Beh, io mi auspico,
che questa araba fenice
schianti una volta per tutte!
Schianti!
(Applausi)
Anche...
Sì, ma anche perché trovi
un po' di pace.
No?
E se proprio deve ri-nascere,
perlomeno che non lasci
troppa cenere in giro.
Grazie!
(Applausi)